Isis yeah have you heard about them this
thing continues and now there's some
interesting stuff coming out of our
media and our government basically that
the stories are not quite matching up if
you listen to what our government is
saying and what our elected officials
are saying it sounds like these strikes
are doing something these airstrikes but
if you listen to our military commanders
no it actually isn't working and the
media is sort of half between because
they don't really do a great job the two
areas that people are focusing on right
now are kobani which is a city on the
turkish-syrian border which is under
attack by Isis and the Kurds are
involved over there and it sounds like
Turkey's kind of attacking the courage
the Kurds are attacking the Turks Isis
is attacking both of them they're both
attacking Isis we're sort of in the
middle of it and then the Anbar province
in Iraq so it is a big freakin mess and
it's completely mixed messages and we
were talking about this a little bit
before the show I don't know what to
believe with any of this anymore I
watched the heading videos I feel like
either they're made up or I can't tell
who's doing them or if they're just
trying to goad us into war and now I'm
listening to you know Josh earnest our
press secretary and I think he's just a
[ __ ] artist and everybody on the
news I don't know what to believe I
don't know what we're doing
take it away Jimmy well I'll say there's
truth there's the two things that I want
to know is okay so why are we there what
what are we trying to accomplish we're
gonna we're not going to destroy Isis we
can't get rid of them
they're people right with a point of
view you can't get rid of a point of
view so and why if Turkey has a third
largest army and Saudi Arabia has the
fourth largest why are we over there
fight now I say this before I told you I
like now I feel like someone gonna go
because of this dummy like I don't I've
been reading as much as I can read no
there's no I don't understand why we are
the ones over there doing this is
because we have what we feel like we
have to fix what we broke in Iraq but
this doesn't start in Iraq it started in
Syria and it started because of a
drought which I've been saying for a
month but so anyway so I don't know why
that's the second thing I know and you
say the beheading videos they must have
known they're trying to go to us that's
exactly what they were doing Dave so
they knew if they cut off the heads of
two American journalists we would bomb
them why would they
do that they wanted us to bomb them
because now they're against the infidel
they're against the big United States so
now all the other Muslims are supposed
to rally to their side which is
happening right so I want to focus on
your first point first which is this
idea that there are these other
countries with armies right there as you
just said Turkey I think it's the third
in Saudi Arabia is it the fourth I'm not
sure but it's pretty it's pretty big we
give all these countries weapons why are
we giving everybody weapons all the time
if they're not allowed to use them or if
they just choose not to use them and
then we still have to do it anyway
doesn't doesn't it make us look kind of
impotent if we don't get involved
whether we have a stake in it or not
don't we just have to do I guess we just
pretty show the world that we're a
presence and we're coming and we're
handling it even if we screw it up worse
maybe we fix it maybe we don't it's a
coin toss but if we don't somehow jump
in and get involved then people forget
we're there good thing I'm saying this
might be the mentality that yeah but if
we're not somehow in the mix then then
all of a sudden we don't count our vote
doesn't catch so we have like an
inferiority complex about war like if
there's a war going on somewhere we
better get involved because we have
follow with war FOMA almost fear usually
snapchatting America does get blamed
either way a lot yes either either
you're so big and powerful and you
couldn't spend five minutes trying to
help these people or why don't you stay
out of it it's not your problem so who
knows anymore you know I think I think
our hands are tied but I don't exactly
think we're there for uh you know
altruistic reasons yeah so what is it
with the are we there Ross all right why
are we there is it are we now gonna try
to install new regimes in some of this
place are we trying to altom utley
topple Assad but it's that I mean we
were literally gonna go to war with
Assad there ago and now we're bombing
the people that are fighting Assad I
mean that's how crazy well that's what
we say we're doing day but if you just
kind of alluded to as a top of the
segment we're we're actually hurting
Assad oh wait a minute I'm is that
intentional when we're saying we're
trying to cuz they wanted to go in and
bomb Assad last year we pushed back we
were completely against it by it for the
record
I'd say we were out in front of that so
they didn't go in but now they got a
couple of beheading videos now we do go
in we start bombing who we say are the B
headers turns out we're bombing Assad
wait a minute maybe that was the plan
all along I don't know because nothing
makes sense so that goes to my original
question how do you know who to trust
when you flick the TV channels and
you're watching this stuff and you know
you're getting propaganda from MSNBC and
Fox and CNN whatever how do you know who
to trust because I have no idea anymore
I have less idea than you because you're
super smart and informed and I'm just
sitting here in a green carrot so yeah
so but then I that question makes me
wonder is anybody in charge does anybody
know what they're doing or is there some
one big secret thing that work that none
of the rest of us are supposed to know
about but it's happening behind the
corner behind the curtains or is the
secret that nobody knows what's going on
and they're just like that's great a
secret of all so maybe we'll just uh
it'll look like you know somebody's in
charge yeah I just you know again a
general Smedley Butler war is a racket
someone's making billions and dollars
off this right now there's a handful of
people getting very rich who have been
getting very rich since 2001 and it's
not stopping
right because we don't have a draft so
it's not gonna ever stop this is gonna
be perpetual war you know what happened
to all this politicians saying we're
broke and we can't afford Social
Security Medicare we can't fix our
bridges erode we have 40 kids per
classroom because we're broke with the
poorest country or world Detroit don't
forget there's no water in Detroit and
except for the fact that we're the
richest country in the world by and we
have a twice the size the economy of
China people forget that yet we're
supposed to be broke we don't have any
money for the people but we have endless
money for bombs in the Middle East
endless I mean how many more billions of
dollars is this good they say 30 years
now we never even discussed it we never
even debated it no one's even talked
about this or what what our goals are
how are we gonna fix it what are we even
trying to fix this is their [ __ ]
territory
these are Sunnis and Shias fighting each
other and they've been fighting each
other for thousands of years and we
think we're gonna fix it with a couple
of cruise missiles yeah by the way we
just signed two weeks ago this agreement
that we're gonna be in Afghanistan for
another 12 years which really means
another 50 years
wait but just two more quick things
because I think we're on to something
here why is it that these countries then
so why is it what does it say about
America that we're so quick to war and I
think maybe you answer this already that
when they're not on our border we still
want to go to war but Turkey Saudi
Arabia all those countries there Lebanon
there they're literally on their border
and yet they're not going to war so what
does that fundamentally say about our
I'm not talking about the establishment
that wants to go to war maybe or the
proper tears I'm just saying the general
Americans that are like let's go to war
what is the parking lot yeah we don't we
have an experienced war on our shores
that's what that says we haven't been
bombed we don't know what that's like so
to us it's a video game right all we
have the only thing we've ever had was
9/11 right but and that was just images
to most of America anyway nobody's town
got bombed nobody had to worry about
their electric electronic Grigg being
bombed nobody had to go through a war
yet in the United States that's what
that is and they think you know they're
manipulated by the media that wants them
to be think that it's okay and everybody
they look to in the media says yes we
have to do this so they think it's okay
that's really interesting so they're
more cautious because they're on the
border where they know if you go to war
it could just come back what you said it
sounds very you know crystallized we'll
let them eat cake just bomb them yeah
level the place what what are we talking
about why are we sitting around talking
just I mean literally again I was at
Disneyland two days ago and there was a
man walking around Fantasyland with a
shirt that says bomb first so this is
what people think a lot of people think
I like how almost everything you'll be
able to bring back to something that
happened Disneyland it's real American
okay last point unless cuz we're going
over we have no congressional authority
for this war well that's on top of
everything else they sort of cheated us
and they said well we were already at
war with Iraq keine so we're just gonna
let that go but then the Syria war there
was no debate Congress went on vacation
Obama didn't call them back but he
doesn't have to they're supposed to do
their job right give war authorization
so I'm more angry at our system I think
then I'm angry at the bomb so I that to
me they've just utterly all of them the
President and Connor they've all just
utterly failed us well do you think
they're taking a sort of relief and that
hey not my fault it's a system of course
that's what they're doing Boehner is
going well Obama should call us back and
have us vote but since when does he want
to give a [ __ ] what what Obama thinks
Jimmy bring us home well politicians are
always gonna act like you know
cowards right and so that's why this
used to be a Fourth Estate that would
keep them honest and call them out on
their [ __ ] so they were always
worried about that
to worry about anymore because the
people there bought the fort the state
the journalists are all on the same side
they all want to go to war they don't
ask the right questions nobody's ever
asked the right question yet and people
like Chuck Todd and David Gregory say
it's not even their job to call out the
government when they're lying us into a
war they say it's not their job than the
top news guys in the country so that's
what's really happening that's why we
have such a dysfunctional government
because journalism the freedom of the
press
journalism is one of the three
professions mentioned in the
Constitution it's a linchpin to our
democracy of Free Press and we don't
have it anymore we have a bought press
so it's Kerr which is corrupt